pour m
on
premier ouvrage consacré à l'oeuvre
d'hergé le monde de tintin de son
compatriote paul van drôme reparaît 35
ans après sa première édition dans la
collection de poche la petite vermillon
à la table ronde
c'est un livre qui prend au sérieux
l'imaginaire d'hergé dont il raconte
sommairement l'existence et qui détaille
sous forme d'aveu à la première personne
la saveur parfois complexes de ses
personnages on sait car j'ai pu
encourager à ses débuts par l'abbé
valaize fondateur du supplément le petit
vingtième
dans lequel tintin déjà flanqué de milou
voit le jour un beau matin de janvier
d'abord lié à l'actualité la nouvelle
russie pour tintin au pays des soviets
et la guerre sino japonaise pour le
lotus bleu hergé s'en affranchit tu
assez vite pour fabriquer sa propre
comédie humaine
inventeur d'un millier de personnages
hauteur d'une vingtaine d'albums
traduisent en 50 langues formidable
metteur en scène de la bande dessinée
jamais démodé à ce jour
r j'ai fait figure de classique de notre
siècle fécond comme balzac ou comme
simenon
sans revenir à ses créations vedette et
pour en rester aux deuxièmes couteaux
qui pourrait oublier l'insupportable
abdallah ou séraphin lampion figure
universelle du casse pieds